bonsoir qui vous m'entendez réussir mon
passage en sixième on me féliciter de
mon travail si dur et si énorme en
primaire le maire de la commune dans
laquelle j'habite et m'a offert un
dictionnaire je ne savait pas à ce
moment là que je l'ouvrirai que huit ans
plus tard pour y rechercher la
définition du mot qui m'avait soi-disant
permis de l'obtenir réussir d'après ce
dictionnaire réussir résulte de
l'accomplissement de quelque chose avec
succès alors d'après la rousse réussir
est un exemple comme celui de réussir la
mayonnaise
mais au delà de toutes les activités et
banal du quotidien réussir devient quand
on est ado comme vous comme moi un
synonyme du mot pression et un antonymes
du mot ambitions as tu réussi ton
exercice de maths
as tu réussi ton un terreau as tu réussi
ton trimestre mais surtout surtout
veux-tu réussir ta vie c'est la question
que je vous pose est ce soir vous avez
tous entre majoritairement entre 12 et
16 ans certains d'entre vous viennent
d'entrer au collège et ont passé l'année
à étudier au maire et l'odyssée d'autres
vont devenir des grands dans quelques
mois en passant le cap du lycée mais
pendant toutes ces années où l'on cache
son téléphone dans sa trousse et où
laurent des devoirs maison très inspiré
de wikipédia on a la pression
vous avez la pression vous devez réussir
votre vie vous devez avoir de bonnes
notes obtenir une moyenne incroyable des
félicitations vous devez suivre une
filière générale au lycée voire même une
voie scientifique parce que vous savez
ça ouvre plus de portes
vous devez avoir votre bac avec mention
puis entrée en lice en semant classes
préparatoires faire un master si vous
êtes un peu fou un doctorat vous devez
entrer dans une grande école qui fera de
vous une grande personne
j'ai ensuite trouvé un travail
satisfaisant mais surtout qui vous fait
gagner de l'argent vos amis là dedans
pas important vos envies souvent dénigré
vos rêves toujours écourtée mais réussir
réussir sa hav de vie
réussir c'est devenu un peu le mot
d'ordre de la société dans laquelle vous
comme moi nous sommes inscrits très tôt
naturellement en allant à l'école en
ayant trop peur des mauvaises notes et
du regard de nos parents vous connaissez
très bien la technique j'ai moi même
utilisé oui maman j'ai eu cinq en maths
mais tu sais tous les ans ma classe ont
eu des mauvaises notes
on critique ceux qui vont dans de
mauvais collège dans de mauvais lycée en
critique laisser happer les littéraires
comme moi les bacs pros et tous ces gens
là finalement depuis notre enfance on
nous a toujours dit que finalement la
réussite était la suite cursus scolaire
parfait pourtant lorsqu on est gamin on
a envie d'être pompier astronautes
pilote de chasse coiffeur on a des
envies des rêves son jugement
ma soeur at its heures désire être
fermière alors je laisse juste imaginer
le jour où elle ira voir son prof de
français
sa prof de maths sont cp ou son
principal et qu'elle dira un conseil de
classe
son rêve quelle sera leur réaction
pourtant et aujourd'hui faire des études
en agriculture est quelque chose d'assez
formidable et permet de faire beaucoup
de choses mais il ya cette peur cette
peur et cette pression de la réussite
scolaire par rapport à ça moi je suis
assez convaincu qu'il ya plusieurs
portes qui s'ouvrent
la première c'est que la réussite n'est
pas forcément forcément ancré sur des
études j'ai eu un parcours un peu
chaotique au collège même si mes parents
ont toujours voulu que je fasse deux
grandes études j'ai finalement après la
classe de 1ère décidé de me concentrer
quasiment à 100% puisque j'ai quand même
continué ma scolarité dans mais ma
passion qui était entreprendre j'ai
monté ma boîte un magazine culturel à
destination de notre génération
j'ai été chroniqueur pour des émissions
télé j'ai écrit un roman chez michel
lafon ce que j'avais en moi cette envie
ce besoin ce désir d'entreprendre dans
un milieu qui crée chez moi une énergie
d'effervescence que l'école ne
m'apportait pas et par rapport à tout ça
malgré tout il faut le dire il ya des
difficultés qui se sont imposés qui se
sont multipliés
des difficultés familiales d'abord je ne
viens pas d'une famille où on a choisi
un a fait des études pour choisir un
travail mais les plutôt le contraire
une famille où on a eu un travail comme
ça qui arrive et qui nous a choisis par
lui même mes parents ont toujours dit
guillaume tu dois faire sciences po
cette phrase j'ai entendu mais des
dizaines de fois à la maison faire une
grande école est une façon pour mes
parents finalement de réussir avec moi
une réussite scolaire qui n'avaient pas
forcément pu avoir
alors ils m'ont toujours soutenu dans ce
que je faisais à côté mais ces pressions
de la réussite moi je n'ai jamais
demandé j'ai jamais choisi véritablement
de faire cette école alors j'ai
travaillé ce concours un peu en retard
tous la voyaient donc j'ai fini par ne
pas l'avoir mais derrière tout ça je me
suis rendu compte que finalement le
système scolaire n'était pas forcément
quelque chose qui était fait pour moi je
me suis rendu compte que ce qui était le
plus important là dedans c'est l
épanouissement personnel qu'on pouvait
avoir
vous savez que l'épanouissement qu'on
peut avoir au quotidien ce moment vous
vous levez le matin parce que vous allez
faire un truc super cool dans votre
journée vous allez sourire vous allez
marcher en rigolant vous allez parler
tout seul
vous allez vous sentir bien dans votre
peau bien au quotidien et c'est quelque
chose que moi j'ai voulu tout de suite
faire dans ma passion dans ce que je
faisais à côté alors j'ai un petit peu
un petit peu abandonné mon rêve de faire
des grandes études de faire une grande
école comme vous l'aimez par an et puis
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
aussi d'autres difficultés qui s'était
présenté à moi tout au long de ce temps
les difficultés scolaires notamment
ça vient d'entreprendre c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas reconnu par
l'éducation nationale
ce n'est pas sportif de haut niveau
musiciens de haut niveau vous ne pouvez
prétendre à aucun aménagement d'emploi
du temps alors c'est à dire que la
compréhension d'escautpont vouloir de
votre chef d'établissement et je vous
avoue que le mien n'a pas été très
compréhensif je me suis pris des heures
de colle injustifiée et on m'a menacé de
me virer plusieurs fois on m'a descendu
sur mobile temps scolaire se fait qu'en
finalité lorsque j'ai fait mes choix sur
parcours sup ça va vous arriver un jour
aussi
eh ben je vais rien eu bah ça ça ça vous
arrivera pas
je n'ai rien dieu est évidemment lorsque
vous êtes cité parmi les 100 personnes
les plus inspirantes par l'express que
vous avez un 14 au bac littéraire
il faut vous rendez compte que vous
n'aviez rien après alors non seulement
ces pressions de la réussite est on ne
peut plus présentes puisque vous avez
peur mais au-delà de ça je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais pris un très gros
coup dans mon ego et que finalement
peut-être que le cursus scolaire ne me
convenait pas vraiment vous savez il ya
quelque chose qui est assez
fondamentalement tout ça c'est la
passion j'ai la chance d'avoir trois
amis qui ont eu d'un parcours scolaire
assez atypique un couteau dans la
normalité j'ai envie de dire qui était
passionné par les sciences politiques et
paraffine à la philosophie qui entrer à
sciences po paris et à la sorbonne et
qui aujourd'hui s'éclate dans tes études
dans cette étude parce qu'il veut en
faire sa vie j'ai mon un autre meilleur
ami qui a arrêté la fac au bout de trois
mois pour se lancer à fond dans sa
passion qui était cinéma sans contact
sans connaître personne il a signé dans
une très grosse maison de production et
verra son film sortir dans quelques
mauvaises mains ma meilleure amie
à 17 ans est parti avec un sac à dos en
tour du monde alors c'est une chaîne
youtube où elle a aujourd'hui deux cent
cinquante mille abonnés et a lancé sa
collection de vêtements eux trois ont
gagné finalement la possibilité de vivre
de leur passion alors ils ont persévéré
et au collège et au lycée bien que ça
les fasse sincèrement ce fait ils ont
continué et ils ont réussi à décrocher
leur bac et parfois contre l'avis de
leurs parents contre l'avis de leurs
professeurs sur tout mais ils ont
surtout gagné la possibilité de vivre de
leur passion et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils ont réussi des choses
formidables et qui sont vraiment
remarquables par rapport à ça par
rapport à tout ça je me suis longuement
questionné sur la possibilité de ce que
je pouvais faire après et finalement je
me suis rendu compte de beaucoup de
choses c'est que le système scolaire
français n'étaient pas forcément très
adapté à des personnes qui avaient envie
de faire des choses à côté économe et
valoriser pas forcément on a quand même
une chance énorme
aujourd'hui nous vivons en france dans
une culture qui est assez incroyable
on a un système éducatif qui est gratuit
et ouvert à tous qui permet d'avoir un
diplôme facilement en soit et quel qu'il
soit un bac 1 c ap un brevet un bac pro
mais l'essentiel c'est ce sésame on va
avoir à la clé et qui va être utile pour
notre futur est le plus essentiel dans
tout ça c'est la persévérance que vous
allez mettre en place la persévérance
pour continuer à croire en vos rêves et
toujours continuer à les développer
vous savez il ya il ya il ya une chose
qui est assez folle c'est que lorsque
j'ai parlé à mes parents du fait que
dernièrement j'avais envie d'arrêter mes
études pour me concentrer à fond dans ma
passion il ya eu cette peur très peur
qui est très très française en disant
oui mais tu sais il te faut un diplôme
il faut absolument que tu valides
quelque chose parce qu'on a fait peur
aujourd'hui contrairement à d'autres
pays notamment en amérique du nord où
les choses sont beaucoup plus facile
pour chacun
et pourtant je me suis rendu compte que
cette culture française on pouvait
peut-être la court-circuiter avec des
gens comme vous des ambassadeurs des
collégiens qui demain vous aussi vous
allez suivre votre cursus passer votre
brevet continuer à voir votre bac mais
demain c'est vous qui serez les
ambassadeurs de ce changement
c'est vous qui sera en capacité de
parler à vos professeurs en leur disant
de ne plus influencé directement sur
votre avenir d'expliquer à vos parents
votre véritable ambition de faire en
sorte que les plus grands comprennent
que la réussite n'est pas forcément une
réussite très scolaire en faisant
sciences po et l'ena et que derrière on
pouvait avoir aussi autre chose d
éclater autrement réussir est très
subjectif réussir et très personnel mais
continuer à croire en vos rêves
continuer à les développer à faire en
sorte qu'il se réalise indépendamment
toujours indépendamment de ce que vous
diront les autres
persévérez toujours persévérer si vous
avez envie de faire un métier technique
ne lâchez rien si vous avez envie de
faire de grandes écoles ne lâchez rien
si vous avez envie de vivre une fille
qui semble totalement bizarre et étrange
ne lâchez rien
si vous avez envie de faire un métier
qui semble précaire je pense ici à tous
les métiers artistiques pourtant qu'ils
sont si beaux ne lâchait rien et une
phrase que j'ai écouté comme sûrement
beaucoup d'entre vous d'orelsan
qui dit tout simplement si tu as envie
de faire des films a juste besoin d'un
truc qui filme dire j'ai pas de matos ou
pas de contacts c'est un truc de
victimes persévérez dans vos rêves
l'humain dans ce pays a une chance qui
est le seul maître de son destin
quoi qu'on dise quels que soient nos
origines alors choisis sont réellement
le nôtre merci
[Applaudissements]